I've been testing and using the Beats
Studio Pro for over a week now and I
gotta say these things are a bit weird
now in this review I'm gonna go over 10
or actually 11 positive things that are
great about these headphones along with
five negatives some that just stump me
now I want to start out with the case
because I absolutely love it compared to
what I am used to the material is nice
and soft but adds protection you have
this nice little grab handle and then
when you unzip it inside we have two
little pockets for storage now I also
love that they include a three and a
half millimeter cable and a USB type-c
cable which is not only for charging but
has a really good data transfer and I'll
talk about that in just a bit and I know
the calving cable is kind of normal but
you don't get that with all of Apple
products these days now one thing I was
weary about when I just got the is the
headband because it's a typical kind of
rubber hard headband and I thought
that'd be uncomfortable and right when
you put them on you definitely notice it
more so than something that is very soft
like the airpods max but I've worn these
for over six hours and the Comfort was
great I never had any buildup of
pressure and with that same thing with
the ear cups you don't have any pressure
that builds up over time and even though
they use this fake leather material that
is non-replaceable I didn't have any
heat build up in my ears now because
these are plastic and they're
lightweight when I went running with
them I didn't have any issues they
weren't moving around a ton like you'd
get with something that's a lot heavier
the Comfort was awesome for working out
so say Comfort wise these are absolutely
excellent but the next positive even
though Apple makes these they are set up
to work great for both iPhones and
Android you get fast pairing on both you
get find my support over there updates
you have an app for Android whereas with
iPhone all your settings are built in
and with that I was really surprised by
how fast they connect to my iPhone and
to my Mac it's a lot faster than the
airpods max which is an older version of
Bluetooth now we compare the microphone
quality in our previous video and it was
fairly close I would say the airpods
were a little bit better go ahead and
take a listen this is the microphone
quality using the the new Beats Studio
Pro and this is the microphone quality
using Apple's airpods Max which are
around two and a half years old now and
now back to the Beats Studio Pro let me
know what you think in terms of Micron
quality which one sounds better down in
the comments below now in the real world
when I use these to make phone calls
people thought that I was talking on my
phone itself the call Quality is
excellent especially with the voice
isolation feature that is supported for
them on the iPhone the next positive is
the massive battery life that is built
into these but in the real world I have
to say this might be slightly deceptive
or at least pushing the marketing
because that is with active noise
cancellation off and most of the time
you're gonna want to use active noise
cancellation which brings it down to 24
hours but with that said the battery
life is still excellent and you can
easily turn it off using the button now
the next positive is the active noise
cancel isolation now I push these to
their limits using my super loud Mower
and they absolutely did a killer job I
didn't have to have music clean and it
blocked out most of that sound now I
compared Dr North's cancellation to the
airpods max in that video using airplane
noise and in that they did not do as
well as the airpods max so I was a bit
disappointed and it was mostly the
higher frequencies that you could hear
more than the airpods max but using my
weed whacker that is also very loud in
this high frequencies it also did killer
blocking out all of that sound and using
in the office it was also great so if
you're worried about that these actually
do a really good job and the next one is
the sound quality we tested three
different tracks on camera and I've
listened to a ton of different music and
I was very impressed now one test that I
did was play low frequency sound waves
because says they mark this as going
down to 20 Hertz and a lot of brands do
this they'll show the lowest possible
but it can't really play at that volume
and I was shocked that at 20 Hertz these
actually played loud enough to be
helpful in music so you get the same
great super deep bass as the airpods max
the high frequencies are also excellent
for some different tracks they actually
sound better than the airpods Max and
you don't get that same kind of boomy
base that could be a bit annoying that
beats had kind of a reputation for you
have a very nice balance sound profile
and nice deep bass so sound quality
would be a major win for me and the next
positive is the loudness these things
get so loud especially with high quality
audio that a lot of times I'm actually
turning them down and I love loud music
and I think this is a great selling
point because sometimes you're listening
to videos or podcasts where the volume
is not not processed properly it's too
low and having that extra overhead to be
able to Crank It Up is very useful and
with that the next positive is the very
low sound leakage with these ear cups
that have this fake leather I was
surprised that when you're playing at
loud volumes they leak way less sound
than the airpods max so if you don't
like annoying other people that are next
to you these do a great job at that and
the last positive that I need to
highlight is the high res audio support
this is awesome you take that USBC cable
you plug it into your Mac and Bam it is
automatically connected feeding It audio
so you don't have to just use that three
and a half mil Jack which you can use
even if the battery is dead on these
which is awesome but plugging that in if
you are playing high resolution lossless
audio it supports it unlike these is way
more expensive headphones and the reason
why these do and these don't is because
with airpods Max it is constantly
processing your audio and down sampling
it where with these when you plug them
in you turn on lossless your active
noise cancellation will turn off
transparency mode will turn off and it's
just giving you that pure high-res audio
and I was shocked that I could
definitely notice a difference sometimes
it's Placebo but in this case the high
frequency sounds are a lot more detailed
and if you want to get the most out of
your audio these support them at this
price point and as for the five issues
the first one is the transparency mode
even though the microphones work well
the transparency mode actually boosts up
your environment more so than in real
life where a lot of headphones you
actually get a quieter sound and because
of this you notice background hiss
different kind of stuff like that and I
think that they should be able to fix
this with the software update and fine
tune it because the microphones do work
well but for now it is not even close to
airpods Max now the next downside is the
fact that when you're listening to these
and you take them off you do not get
Auto pause and that absolutely blows my
mind for 350 dollar headphones there's
headphones that are under 100 bucks that
support this now with that the next one
is the fact that when you close these
down and I love that you can close them
down like this and store them in your
bag well you do not get Auto off and
then Auto on when you open them you have
to use the little button right here and
from me I think this little button is
just too small it's too close you kind
of have to search for it sure you'll get
used to it but they could have done a
better job why not put this in on
headphones that are 350 dollars you know
they have them in their other beats that
we tested before and I love that feature
you have to Fumble around and apple just
took that away whereas they put in a
gyroscope in here for spatial audio and
head tracking that's an extra cost you
know they did some extra things but it's
almost like they did that on purpose to
give airpods Max you know some benefits
over these headphones and the next
downside is the fit and finish and the
feel these things are super plasticky
the design is pretty much the same from
2017 and they just Creak and they crack
and they don't feel really good and with
that the controls on the side the
buttons also do not feel really high
quality to be completely honest these
feel like headphones that would be
around the 100 price range and that kind
of sucks when you're spending 350 bucks
now of course they're lightweight but
there's other lightweight headphones
that are plastic that feel much better
and that leads into the last kind of
downside and that is the price tag at
350 bucks the value is really up to you
some people will say wow that's a lot of
money for headphones while others will
say the sound quality is great you have
the the high-res audio support with USB
type c the you know some of the other
features are really nice but it's also
lacking features of course this is made
by beats which is now owned by Apple
they like to price their stuff really
high and I just feel like either they
could have added you know the auto pause
the on and off when you close it and you
open it maybe made it feel a bit better
for that price tag or maybe just drop
the price a little bit lower but with
all of that said after using these for a
week I really like them and the
downsides while they suck there's other
positives that outweigh it and I think
if you're making a choice right now to
buy one or the other I would go for the
Beats they are very very nice check out
the link down below there's often sales
shortly after these come out click that
Circle above and check out our full
comparison right over there that's been
Max and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]